[Music]
what's the first thing you should do if
you ever fall into a pool full of
stingrays they may look super cute but
don't let their friendliness fool you
because they're also carrying a long
venomous serrated stinger that could
kill you at any moment
so should you swim out of there as fast
as you can or stay close to the surface
of the water or should you just dance on
the bottom of the pool this is what if
and here's what would happen if you fell
into a pool of stingrays the first thing
you need to do when you find yourself
swimming with stingrays is to keep your
feet away from them one way to do this
would be to stay as close to the surface
as possible but another more fun way
would be to do something called the
Stingray shuffle this method involves
carefully standing in the pool and
shuffling your feet along the bottom in
whatever direction you wish to go it may
look silly but if you were to try and
walk across the pool you'd risk kicking
or stepping on one of the stingrays and
that would be a quick way to meet their
deadly stinger what is it about this
thin spiny tail that can be so dangerous
the long sharp spine at the end of a
stingrays tail is known as its barbed if
you were stung by the stingrays barb it
would cause serious damage because it
would go into your body smoothly like a
nail
but it's serrated edges would tear up
your tissues on the way out like pulling
out a screw and that's just the
beginning as the serrated edges sink
into you the stingrays venom would flow
into your wounds the venom is not
necessarily fatal but it does hurt a lot
it's composed of the enzymes v nucleo
today's and phosphatase Turing's
and the neurotransmitter serotonin if
you're wondering why I'd even try to
pronounce these three big names for you
it's because they're important
especially the last one
serotonin causes smooth muscle to
severely contract and this is what makes
the venom so painful some victims who
have been stung in their feet say that
the pain is like squeezing your foot in
a vise and twisting it let's try to
avoid that the first thing to keep in
mind when you drop into a pool of
stingrays is that they're naturally
docile creatures who will only attack in
self-defense they're so gentle that in
the Cayman Islands there's even an
extremely popular tourist attraction
called Stingray City where people feed
and swim with large groups of stingrays
but even though these stingrays are
friendly and love being fed they still
sting some people
the best way to avoid being stung is to
make sure you don't kick or step on any
of the stingrays if a stingray feels
threatened it will flip its tail upwards
over its body
striking whatever's in front of it the
stingray doesn't control the release of
its venom only the movement of its tail
if you accidentally step on one and get
stung you need to get out of the pool as
soon as you can without getting stung
again if the wound is superficial it
needs to be treated right away pull the
Stinger out and apply pressure on the
bleeding to encourage the venom to come
out it's important to listen to your
body because it is possible to have a
life-threatening allergic reaction to
the venom if your assure that you're not
having an allergic reaction
use hot water around 43 to 46 degrees to
kill the venom and relieve the pain once
the pain has been relieved apply
antibiotic ointment or cream on the
wound and cover it with bandages
if the barb has punctured your abdomen
chest throat or neck or has completely
gone through a part of your body do not
remove it you need emergency medical
treatment as soon as possible
but if you had just followed our advice
from the beginning you wouldn't have to
worry about any of this because you
would have been able to avoid getting
stung stingrays aren't really that
dangerous if you treat them right
so when it comes to choosing creatures
to swim with you could do a lot worse
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]